[Music]
on this Tuesday night catastrophic
flooding in California there's just a
lot of infrastructure that isn't
designed for drainage the destruction
from a deluge the rescues and the fear
of what's coming
a warning about our planet getting
warmer the climate crisis here the fight
against Rising temperatures and false
information
battle Brewing Alberta's Premier pushing
back on ottawa's plan to help oil and
gas workers transition to clean energy
jobs
and would you wear these how much dough
you'll need to buy Nike's Ode to
Montreal Bagels
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin tonight in California where flash
floods mudslides and torrential rain is
threatening millions of people the
onslaught of storms began in late
December and it has been Relentless up
to 18 centimeters more rain was expected
today adding to weeks of storms that
have dumped rainfall four to six hundred
percent above normal levels almost 90
percent of California and about 33
million people are under flood warnings
that includes downtown L.A those risks
along with the potential for drastic
mudslides have prompted evacuation
orders for thousands of people
specifically in Montecito and along the
Santa Barbara coast roads have been
washed out and there are fears houses
could be swept away by Cascades of mud
over 200 thousand customers are without
power and at least 16 people have died
in these powerful atmospheric Rivers
thrashing the West Coast more rain is
forecast Jackson prosco has our top
story tonight
California just can't catch a break with
storm after storm pounding the state an
unrelenting Deluge this overflowing
Creek and coming in this time the water
came so fast people struggled to escape
the flash floods as huge pieces of
debris were washed away destroying
everything in their path it was just a
shocker and where we it was it was just
unbelievable a five-year-old boy was
swept away after the car he was
traveling in with his mother was
overwhelmed so far Rescuers have only
found his shoe
dozens of people were plucked to safety
rescued by air
and from below ground where a mother and
daughter had to be pulled from a
sinkhole that swallowed two cars we're
in the midst of a series of significant
and Powerful storms
thousands of Californians are under
evacuation orders as officials fear more
mudslides like this one
over the last few weeks a series of
atmospheric Rivers has pummeled the
state with an entire season's worth of
rain
in the oversaturated soil little stands
a chance and there's still more to come
the parade of storms continue it looks
like Northern California will bear the
brunt in the coming days and then this
weekend the rest of the state will once
again see heavy rainfall Mountain snow
and potential flooding
damage is likely to run into the
billions while residents are left to
pick through the muddy mess this is the
biggest flood that we've seen since
we've been here it's crazy to see the
flood line you know overhead in a state
plagued by disastrous fires and parched
by drought rain was welcome but not so
much so fast scientists warn it could
all be part of a new normal in a
changing climate where California is
more vulnerable than ever to floods that
once seemed unthinkable
Jackson prosco Global News
we can expect more weather disasters
like that because of extremes triggered
by climate change and new data shows the
world is warming at an alarming Pace the
past eight years were the eight hottest
on record temperatures are now 1.2
degrees Celsius warmer than in the
second half of the 19th century and last
summer was the hottest on record in
Europe the European continent just like
Canada is warming much faster than the
rest of the planet a trend that is
fueling concerns about more catastrophic
weather to come Eric Sorensen explains
extremes just in the last year the
atmospheric rivers in the Pacific
Europe's heat wave that saw London break
temperature records the tropical
hurricane that brought destruction as
far north as Newfoundland and Labrador
and the constant accelerating loss of
ice in Canada's Arctic all have one
Trend in common according to the eu's
Copernicus climate change service human
activity is warming the planet and
experts say more extremes are coming the
trend is uh exactly parallel with the
with the climate scientists forecasts
the climate crisis here and and we have
to make steps against it immediately the
last hundred years global temperatures
have changed from patterns of cooler and
warmer to increasingly warm years
especially recently the hottest years of
all were in 2016 and 2020. now 2022
shows overall another exceedingly warmer
year for global temperatures it was
cooler this past year over the Canadian
prairies for example and look at the
cool La Nina current in the Pacific it
would normally suppress global
temperatures and yet this was still the
fifth hottest year on record the global
temperature average shows the steady
rise the last 40 years with the last
eight years since 2014 being the eight
hottest years ever
unfortunately the trend is not
reversible in the near future if we were
to actually reduce our greenhouse gas
and Emissions to zero tomorrow
we would see no slowing in the rate of
warming of the climate system for at
least 20 30 40 years Gordon McBean says
governments must work together within
Nations and internationally to reduce
emissions but also to adapt our
infrastructure and change how we live to
mitigate the harm from climate change
while preparing for the extremes still
to come we have to learn to adapt but we
also need to reduce our emissions so
that we don't go to totally destructive
temperatures McBean says climate science
must be reported repeated and
continually updated to counter the false
information that so many people seek out
he says Canadians have added incentive
to engage on climate change because of
our Northern latitude this country is
warming at twice the global average and
the Canadian Arctic is warming three to
four times faster Eric Sorensen Global
News Toronto
burning fossil fuels is the largest
source of greenhouse gas emissions a
little later Heather York's West looks
at the just transition shifting workers
to clean energy jobs it is a Hot Topic
in Alberta but first in British Columbia
a police officer has died and another is
critically injured after they were
caught in an avalanche in the province's
west Kootenai region the off-duty
officers were skiing in a remote area
north of Nelson when they were swept
down the mountain 28 year old Constable
Machu nolay remains in intensive care
43-year-old Constable Wade titamore did
not survive
we're a small police force with a true
family Dynamic and this tragedy is
devastating to us here at Nelson
these are fine men and fine officers and
the whole Community is hurting
Avalanche Canada says the snowpack
across much of western Canada is
dangerously weak experts are comparing
it to the conditions in 2003 one of the
deadliest avalancheers on record
the federal government has appointed a
special representative to help address
one of the calls for justice in the
National inquiry into missing and
murdered indigenous women and girls
Jennifer Moore rattray will provide
advice and recommendations to support
the creation of an indigenous and human
rights ombuds person
through the engagement with family
survivors and partners Miss more
actually will provide us with guidance
and advice on how to best address this
critical call for justice on
accountability in particular in a way
that is both meaningful and relevant
more rattray is the former executive
director of the national inquiry into
missing and murdered indigenous women
and girls
Toronto police have identified the man
killed in a stabbing last month
59-year-old Ken Lee was stabbed on
December 18th and died later in hospital
eight girls between the ages of 13 and
16 were arrested police believe they had
congregated from across the GTA after
meeting online all of them have been
charged with second-degree murder
Canada will buy an American-made
surface-to-air missile system worth
hundreds of millions of dollars for
Ukraine that announcement was made in
Mexico City today at the so-called Three
Amigos Summit of leaders from Canada the
U.S and Mexico border security and
migration are also on the agenda but as
Mackenzie gray reports Nations outside
of North America were top of mind today
The Three Amigos meeting in Sunny Mexico
City marking the prime minister's first
major trip of 2023. North America is the
largest free trading block in the world
larger even than the European Union
Trudeau's trade focused trip paid off in
part a dispute between Canada and the
U.S over the treatment of American
Border guards has significantly slowed
the popular Nexus program since March
2020 but today a breakthrough in the
spring Canadian applicants will be able
to get an interview at certain Canadian
airports and then fly to the U.S to
complete their American Nexus interviews
welcome news for the nearly hundred
thousand Canadians on the waitlist the
reality is we want Americans want
Canadians to come and have easy access
to our country for tourism and travel
and trade
the war in Ukraine also a major topic
with Canada announcing their single
biggest military purchase for Ukraine
yet
spending 406 million dollars to buy
American-made National Advanced service
to air missile systems which are highly
effective at shooting down Russian
drones and Rockets having a narrow
defense system available to the Ukraine
is literally a life and death issue if
you don't have air defense nowadays in a
contemporary or against a relatively
modern foe you will die the purchase
welcomed by Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski thanking Canada for protecting
Ukrainian Skies but unlike other weapons
given to Ukraine Canada itself lacks
this capability the Canadian Armed
Forces has no zero none air defense
systems from the ground to the air
and I would challenge anybody any
academic scholar out there to find me
one other army in the world that has no
air defense systems
in another International crisis the
Biden Administration pushing for help on
Haiti hoping Canada would lead a
security Force to try and deal with
gangs block hitting ports and frequent
kidnappings shooter wouldn't commit to
that instead focusing on sanctions and
aid for local police what we do this
time allows for the Haitian people to
get the situation under control and a
big part of that is putting those
sanctions on the Haitian leadership Joe
Biden also told Trudeau that he would
visit Canada in March now there's no
date or itinerary yet for the
president's trip but it will be the
first visit of a sitting president here
in Ottawa since Barack Obama addressed
parliament in 2016. Donna and that was a
while ago Mackenzie gray in Ottawa
thanks the U.S president is facing
criticism after some classified
documents dating back to when he was
vice president were found at his former
private office Joe Biden's personal
lawyers discovered about 10 files some
marked Top Secret in a locked Closet in
his Washington Office of the think tank
the Penn Biden Center the next day they
were handed over to the National Archive
lives and the matter is under review by
the justice department Biden's critics
are comparing it to the discovery of top
secret documents found in a raid of
former president Donald Trump's Florida
estate hundreds of documents were found
there in Trump's possession and he
repeatedly resisted requests to return
the materials
the Biden Administration is under
growing pressure to expel Brazil's
far-right former president jair
bolsonaro from the U.S after his
supporters Brazen attack on Brazil's
capital bolsonaro was admitted to a
Florida Hospital on Monday with stomach
pains he says he's now been discharged
his supporters want him restored to
power and the newly inaugurated leftist
president who won the election
ousted many of those arrested after the
riot were released by the police today
after being questioned more than a
thousand people were detained after that
anti-government attack
Peru has barred former Bolivian
president Evo Morales from entering the
country as Peru blames foreign left-wing
interests for the latest round of deadly
protests in that country's South
violence intensified on Monday with the
country's human rights office saying at
least 17 people were killed in brawls
between anti-government protesters and
police overall nearly 40 deaths have
been connected to the weeks-long unrest
demonstrations started in December
they've been met by a harsh government
Crackdown that's been criticized heavily
by Morales one of the Region's most
prominent leftists
the UK's Failure to Launch coming up why
there's still optimism about launching
satellites from the UK
[Music]
Alberta's Premier is pushing back on
plans by the federal government to
introduce new legislation about the
transition from jobs in the oil and gas
industry to clean energy a bill to help
them transition was a campaign promise
of the federal liberals Alberta's
Premier doesn't like it and as Heather
urick's West reports that setting the
stage for a battle that could help
everyone but the workers themselves
Chad Miller built a successful career in
Alberta's oil fields but after 25 years
Miller is making a backup plan
developing a mobile educational game
about drilling that he hopes to turn
into a successful business sooner or
later push comes a shove they are going
to wean a lot of this down and there's
nothing we can do yeah after you don't
driven out of the sector by punishing
boom bust cycles and an uncertain future
oil and gas workers are leaving faster
than the industry can cope we did a
survey and in the Energy Services sector
Supply and Manufacturing alone we have
close to 3 000 job openings it's why
industry Advocates like inserva are
concerned about the timing of the
liberal government's just transition
legislation the bill to help workers
move from oil and gas to clean energy
jobs is expected to be introduced early
this year we will continue to Advocate
on behalf of the hundreds of thousands
of workers whose livelihoods depend on
this industry and we expect the federal
government to stand up for our world
leading oil and natural gas workers
instead of trying to eliminate their
jobs Alberta and ottawa's looming battle
over the future of these workers comes
with plenty to gain both for the Prime
Minister and Danielle Smith who faces an
election in just four months but this
isn't just political posturing there's
also a really profoundly important
policy issue that's at stake here and
that is whether Canada is going to take
significant action to reduce greenhouse
gas emissions and the fact is Canada
cannot reach its emissions targets if
the oil and gas sector doesn't make a
big change it's why workers like Miller
aren't waiting around you save a bunch
of money for the time that you're down
and then all of a sudden the government
will throw in a wrench in it and then
you don't know whether or not you're
going to go to work or or have to
transition to a different career
and it's hard on yourself it's hard on
your mental stability and it's and your
family in a global energy transition
nobody wants to be left behind Heather
your ex West Global News Calgary
out of pocket ahead inflation's impact
on a Halifax entrepreneur
[Music]
property owners in Toronto are facing a
big hike in taxes Mayor John Tory table
the city's budget for 2023 he says
torontonians can expect a 5.5 percent
property tax hike that would cost the
average household an additional 233
dollars Tori says the hike is necessary
to maintain city services we know
inflation is having an impact on
Canadians of all walks of life tonight
in the first of a series we go to
Halifax to see how a young professional
is running a small business in addition
to her full-time job and still finding
it hard to make ends meet Amber Friday
brings us her story
it's been just over a year since Megan
Simon started a small charcuterie
business and despite the rising costs of
food she insisted on keeping her prices
the same for as long as possible so they
betrayed the package of cheese got
smaller and the price got higher and
then delivery paid apart because gas was
going up all just consistently week
after week meanwhile in addition to her
entrepreneurial venture Simons also
works a full-time job she says she never
imagined the economic climate would be
this dire I didn't anticipate it would
hit me this hard like I didn't think it
would be this hard this fast I just pay
attention to a lot more things when I'm
consuming how I'm consuming it how
frequently meanwhile Economist Stephen
Brown says the inflation increase has
been double what was projected you know
even The Economist that was suggesting
inflation would be high misread how high
it would go you know partly that was due
to the war in Ukraine pushing up
commodity prices but I would wouldn't
say it was all that we I think we've
also underestimated inflation pressures
elsewhere too Brown says he intested
headline inflation will drop below two
percent next year and that there could
be a moderate recession but there's been
a lot of Market optimism in the last few
weeks because China's you know has eased
its sort of covert restrictions in
theory that means the economy should
recover but I think the route to the
full recovery is not going to be a
pleasant one but in the face of
inflation Simon says she's grateful that
it hasn't impacted demand new clients
will still come on old clients still
making the same orders as well Simon
says even through the trying time she is
eagerly anticipating expanding her
business in the near future she hopes to
become a sommelier so she can offer an
in-home wine tasting along with her
shakuturi experience Amber Friday Global
News Dartmouth Nova Scotia
no space for error next why a failed
rocket launch isn't a complete loss
[Music]
good speed Cosmic girl on this historic
with European and UK mission to open
space for everyone this Boeing 747 took
off from England last night on a mission
to make history but it didn't quite work
out the Virgin orbit flight was supposed
to launch a rocket carrying satellites
into orbit a first for the UK there was
a huge crowd watching and millions on
the line but it didn't happen Redmond
Shannon explains what went wrong and why
Engineers are not giving up
when we think of launching satellites
into space this is normally what comes
to mind
but this takeoff from Southwest England
is part of the new era of commercial
space launches an attempt to send the
first ever satellites into orbit from
Western European soil the rocket
deployed like this from the wing of a
jumbo jet at 35
000 feet it appears that launch one has
suffered anomaly but unfortunately
something went wrong with the rocket
just as it was reaching orbit absolutely
devastated
um you know we put our heart and soul
into this and it's such a personal
Journey for me as well and my family
were here Canadian Melissa Thorpe is the
head of England's new Spaceport still
digesting the loss of the nine small
satellites into the Atlantic Ocean
feeling better yeah it was pretty pretty
upsetting initially but it is space and
you know you've got to get back up and
do it again her customer virgin orbit
isn't too discouraged four of its five
previous launches from California made
it to space if you look at one of the
most successful launch companies right
now that's SpaceX you only have to look
at the early days to realize that they
were very very close to um to failing
many of their early Rockets failed
virgin orbit part owner Richard Branson
also used horizontal launches for his
Virgin Galactic space trips or part of
the space boom globally you know I think
there's something like 70 new spaceports
plant around the world I know even
Canada has few in the pipeline pipeline
including one plan for Nova Scotia which
will use vertical rocket launch pads
with plans to launch satellites from the
maritimes as early as 2025. Redmond
Shannon Global News London
if you know anyone chasing the latest
sneaker you're going to want to know
about this Nike is releasing the dunk
low Montreal bagel the limited edition
Montreal bagel sneaker is described as
having carb lover colors otherwise known
as beige and they're sprinkled with
sesame seeds Nike says the blue swoosh
is a shout out to the city from LaBelle
Provence you'll have to Shell out 120
U.S if you're a hard-earned doe reviews
are mixed some people are holding out
for the poppy seed version
and that is global national for this
Tuesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
Canada is North Bay Ontario we'd love to
see your Canada please email it to
viewers at globalnational.com thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]